[Music]
okay
thank you all for being here so i'm just
going to present a little bit about a
package that i've been working on over
the last couple months called live code
so i teach a lot of statistical
programming classes to a variety of
different
student levels and one of the tools i've
been adopting more and more my teaching
is this idea of live coding and these
are a couple quotes from some academic
papers from the computer science
literature about
what is live coding i think we all
probably have a pretty good idea
but i think one of the key things at
least coming at it from an educator's
perspective
is this idea of when we're teaching
people to code one of the things we want
to do
is show them the thought process so we
don't want to just show them finished
code we want to show the process of
generating code
and also talk about and narrate the
thought process that goes into
solving that kind of thing and i think
this is a really important powerful tool
and i've been
sort of using it more and more in my
teaching but
this is sort of in conflict with another
sort of big idea within pedagogy which
is this idea of active versus passive
learning
the general preferences we want our
students to be doing active things
engaging things doing stuff with their
hands that kind of idea
live coding is sort of inherently
passive they're sitting there watching
you code things they're listening to
what you talk about
and in the little bit where it tends to
be active it's active in not a great way
the students will sit there and they'll
type the same code that you're typing
they're repeating that same effort
and then they're not listening to what
you're saying which is sort of the most
valuable thing that's going on here
so live code is sort of an effort that
i'm trying to make to move some of this
stuff away from sort of just purely
passive absorbing that information
into a more active learning kind of
thing particularly leveraging our studio
in this interactive environment
to get them playing around with code to
explore it and learn in that way
so this is a screencast of the package
reload it so it
launches so live code has a lot going on
don't worry about the code right now
it's just running one function called
serve file what it's doing is it's
looking at the file that i currently
have in our open in our studio
launching a server making that available
and
what it's doing in real time or close to
real time is syncing the contents of
that file in my r studio session
to a web page that the students can go
to and log in on so if you see
this sort of little banner thing in the
blue picture up in the upper right hand
corner
here what we see is that we're saying
welcome to live code we're serving
example dot
r at and then a bit link that they can
connect to
all of this went by a little quick so
i'll play it again and try to narrate a
little bit
so we launch the server it figures out
from the context what it should be doing
figures out my local network environment
and
i get this server running locally but
that link should now be accessible to
other people
they can click on it connect and so here
i'm just demonstrating it by two
sessions that are running simultaneously
the idea is i should be able to scale
this up to
50 or 100 or even 200 students other
things we see that we get syntax
highlighting
note as i make changes in the file in
our studio that changes propagating
over to the session in the web browser
and other sort of nice quality of life
things like if we look at
the line that's highlighted in the
web server is the same thing where my
cursor is in the file
in our studio so we're trying to sync
all of this kind of stuff and
there's a lot of things going on behind
the scenes here but this is really
leveraging a lot of the powerful tools
that our studio has written for doing
asynchronous programming so if you heard
winston chang's wonderful talk yesterday
we're doing all of that kind of stuff to
make this sort of seamless
but the goal is to make this as
accessible to educators as possible
to give you a little bit more of an idea
about what's sort of going on behind the
scenes
this is the main function this is mainly
the thing that you should interact with
so before i ran it without any arguments
but it's using things from the rstudio
api to figure out okay
what file do you have currently open i
had a file called example.r
so it's picking that out for me and
doing it other things like specifying
the ip address that you want the server
to run on
most people who are probably going to
use this don't want to know about
running a server don't want to know
about ip addresses or ports
so one of the things that the package
tries to do is figure that out for you
automatically
so here it's using this 10 dot port
if you know something about ip addresses
that's a private ip address so this is
actually from me running this
on the hotel network here that's not
something that's accessible to the
outside world
i can't do anything about that as a
package maintainer but i can at least
give my users some information about
that saying hey
you're on a private ip address only
other people are on that same network
will probably be able to access it so
again trying to provide some feedback
tell you what's going on there
auto save so again this is trying to do
this in a sort of nice elegant way
so we can leverage our studio to save
the files
automatically and then only push things
to our users
when we actually make a change so we're
not constantly pushing the same file
over and over again
we wait for a change when that happens
it gets sent out to everybody otherwise
we don't do things
and depending on how big the file is and
how many people you have connected
we can set that interval in terms of
when it pulls things to be slower or
faster so i can send changes out every
two minutes
so on and so forth and we're playing
with other kind of cool things like
sending messages to your users that kind
of thing
and it's very early days for the package
but we'd like you to play with it
try to break it try to stress test it
that kind of thing and let us know how
it goes
[Music]